[MUSIC PLAYING]
JACK TEELING: Hi, guys.
Is this working?
Yeah.
That's good.
I'm delighted to be here.
It's great to see that the
draw of some free whiskey
on a Friday afternoon still
gets people interested.
It's [INAUDIBLE] to be here.
I'm here just to tell you
a little bit about who
we are, what we're trying to
do, and at the same time maybe
impart some nuggets
of information linked
into the rich provenance and
heritage of Dublin and Ireland
in the evolution
of global whiskey.
Because there's lots of
hidden stories and messages
that have been
lost along the way.
And we're lucky,
myself and my brother.
We're just the
latest generations
of Teelings involved
in the industry,
and we're trying to
put our own mark on it.
And we like to say we're
respectful to the past,
but we're confident
to forge a new future.
But to do that, you need to
know where you've come from.
So just very, very
quickly people
don't know that, actually,
whiskey distillation
comes from Ireland.
It was actually the Irish monks
who traveled around the world
and they saw in the Middle
East and the Mediterranean
the curious process
of distillation
using alembic stills
making essential oils,
making eau de vie, and they
took that technology back
to Ireland.
And we didn't have the same
crops, but what there was,
there was lots of barley.
And they soon figured out that
the resulting spirit or liquid
had medicinal values, and
that technology moved all
around the world.
So it went to Scotland and
it went everywhere else.
But it was very
much a mom and pop.
It's very, very
small production.
So it literally was on
farms and really catering
for the local community.
But a couple of
different things changed
from the 18th and 19th century.
Our family first started in
1782 in a small craft distillery
in the city center of Dublin.
One of 40 other ones.
And out of these
small distilleries
came the giants that really
drove the last golden era
for Irish whiskey
in the 19th century
when Irish whiskey dominated.
Much bigger than scotch.
Much bigger than
American whiskey.
We dominated.
Around 70% of all
global exports came out
of the islands of Ireland.
And there was a reason for
that because we had, even
back in the 17th, 18th
century, a quality reputation.
It was always seen as smooth
and very, very drinkable.
And one thing happened at the
start of the 19th century--
it was the Act of Union with the
British empire, which was not
so good for the country, but
great for Irish whiskey sales
because all of a
sudden it opened up
all the markets around the
world to Irish whiskey.
It also led to a lot of
foreign direct investment.
So a lot of money
came into Ireland.
And at that time, Dublin
was the second richest city
in the whole of the British
empire, and a lot of money
went into whiskey
distillation, in particular.
Because of the
Industrial Revolution,
the smaller distilleries
could become much bigger.
And it was quite
interesting in that when
you think of distillation,
you think of rolling hills,
you think of lochs,
and all that.
In Ireland, it was urban.
It was in city centers because
it was linked to the ports
and it could export
around the world.
So it was very, very
different than what
was happening in Scotland.
Well, unfortunately,
we lost our way.
I think success
breeds arrogance,
and we didn't adapt
to modern technology,
and one or two other things
happened in the 20th century.
The War of Independence,
which was great, again,
for the country, but dreadful
for Irish whiskey sales
because it stowed away all the
routes to market that we had.
And from the 1930s
to the 1990s, it
was the dark days
for Irish whiskey
because the last big
export market was the US,
and they had prohibition.
So it was like a car crash
and we fell off a cliff,
and a lot of the old brands and
a lot of the old distilleries
slowly slipped away.
And what's interesting
and what's unique, really,
about our city and the city
that you guys find yourself,
this is the cradle of
urban whiskey distillation.
It was here in the city.
Because, as I said, it wasn't
these rural distilleries that
were driving that golden
era, it was distilleries
in the city center of Dublin.
And really, in the area
called The Liberties,
which was outside
of the city wall.
And the reason why it
was called The liberties,
because you're at liberty do
whatever the hell you wanted.
It was famous for manufacturing.
It was for breweries, it was for
distilleries, it was for linen,
and for brothels, and so forth.
But the one that
stood the test of time
was distilleries and breweries.
And there was so much production
in one square kilometer
in The Liberties, it was
called the Golden Triangle.
It was where majority
of the whiskey sold
in the last golden era of
Irish whiskey came from.
But it was a very
dark day in 1976
when the last Dublin distillery
shut its doors, when Powers
shut its doors, and
all the production
was consolidated down into
one distillery in Cork--
in the Midleton Distillery.
So from the 1976 onwards,
all the rich heritage
and provenance and all
the stories and characters
that were linked into
making whiskey in our city
slowly slipped away,
until recently.
So where are we now?
We are in a new golden
era for Irish whiskey.
Irish whiskey,
since the 1990s, has
been the fastest
growing spirits category
in the world, as a new
generation of people
discover the joys
of Irish whiskey.
Irish whiskey, because of our
climate and the way we make it,
it's a little bit lighter, it's
a little bit more accessible,
and it's a perfect gateway
spirit into whiskey in general.
Everything is cyclical.
So they say you don't drink
what your parents drink,
but you might drink what
your grandparents drink.
And it's really Irish
whiskey's chance to shine.
And it's still only at the
early stages of segmentation.
For years, there's only been
a handful of distilleries.
So in 2012 when I set up, there
was only four distilleries.
Now there there's
20 plus, and more
coming very quickly behind.
So it's going to change.
It's going to evolve.
It's going to be
a proper category
with lots of different styles
and expression for people
to discover.
And it's hopefully going to
double from where we are now
over the next 10 years.
And why is it happening?
It's really down to
consumer behavior.
Consumer younger people, like
all your good selves here,
are much more progressive.
They don't stick with brands.
They like to discover
something new.
They want to find
something that's relevant
that can connect to themselves.
And they're enjoying whiskey of
every kind in different ways.
Before Irish whiskey
was very much
Irish coffees
around the holidays
for Irish American families,
and so forth, but it's changing.
It's part of a cocktail.
It's being used and drunk
in many different ways.
And straight, of course.
And the engine for that
growth is the US market.
So it was the market
that put the final nail
in the coffin of Irish
whiskey at the start
of the 20th century, but
it's driving, let's say,
the evolution and the
revolution of the category now.
It's grown way over
600% the last 10 years.
But for us, the premiumization
at the higher end of the market
is the one that's
growing very, very fast.
But why are people drinking it?
I touched on that.
It's a sense of discovery.
It's become part
of popular culture.
But at the core is the taste.
People enjoy the taste
of Irish whiskey.
Our lovely, miserable, temperate
climate is good for one thing,
and that's producing--
as they say,
a soft climate produces a
soft whiskey, but it's true.
It's true.
Because if you took a
distillery that's in Ireland
and you made the spirits,
but you matured it
in the highlands of Scotland,
or in Kentucky, or in Taiwan,
or in Japan, anywhere else,
it would be totally different.
The cask and the maturation
delivers 60% to 70%
of the flavor.
And what's distinctive
about Irish whiskey
is the temperate, soft
climate that produces limited,
let's say, movement of the wood.
Because oak casks are porous
and they deliver majority of it.
So it's environmental influence.
So when you think
of Irish whiskey,
it's because we don't get
to go to the beach too often
and we have to always
carry a raincoat with us,
but it delivers exceptional
quality whiskey.
And when I set up in 2012,
I had worked in a company
called Cooley Distillery.
It had been set up
by my father in 1987.
It was the first new distillery
in Ireland in over 100 years,
and we tried to revive a
lot of old, famous brands.
And I went around the US and
all around the world trying
to promote them,
and I saw for myself
the emergence of craft spirits,
craft beer, people going back
into urban centers to try
and make things and create
brands that were relevant to the
people that live around there.
And it planted a
seed in my head.
And when my father decided
to sell the company
he was in in 2011,
2012, [INAUDIBLE]..
But it allowed me a chance to
take all these little nuggets
of information and the
things that I really
wanted to do and really attack
the category in my own way.
And my vision was to bring a
more contemporary, more modern
representation of what
Dublin and Ireland is
rather than the traditional
rolling hills, red setters,
and all that kind of stuff
for me, as a modern Dubliner,
didn't really connect to me.
And it's kind of like going
to O'Carroll's gift shop
and you see all that
paddywhackery stuff.
It's not real.
It's not really what's going on.
So I thought there
was an opportunity
to represent Ireland and
Dublin in a modern way
and put my own mark
on it, but do it
in a way that was
very relevant to me
and to go right back to
where our family first
started distilling, which
was in the city of Dublin.
And these are the other players.
Pernod Ricard, the biggest
player by a long way.
Jameson is a phenomenal
success story.
Absolutely amazing.
But we won't go into
that because I already
talked about that.
William Grant and Sons,
they own Tullamore Dew.
They bought that a
good few years ago now,
but they're the
largest privately owned
scotch whiskey company.
And Diageo, the biggest
drinks company in the world,
used to own Bushmills
at the time.
They subsequently flipped it
and bought a premium tequila,
but they're coming
back into it as well.
So the concept was to
do something different.
To do something very unique.
And that was to come back
to the city center of Dublin
and do it.
So as I said, all of it
being contemporary, urban,
innovative, celebrating
my own unique provenance
and doing something a
little bit different.
But at the core of it was
to get back into production
as soon as possible.
But also, as we said, whiskey
is a very traditional category.
You can't treat whiskey
like a white spirit,
like a vodka or gin because of
all the history and so forth.
If you look at all
the old brands,
they've been around
for hundreds of years.
So you're competing
against that.
And the certain
consumer expectations
of what it should look like.
So we see ourselves as the
disruptor of Irish whiskey,
but at the same
time, we're quite--
you'd probably go,
you're quite traditional.
Because that's
what people expect.
And if you go too far, people
actually lose credibility
and they think you're
overcompensating for something
crap in the bottle.
So what we have done
is we are, let's say,
celebrating the past.
We've gone with an
old style dark bottle.
It's the way that
they would have
been able to make glass
back in the 19th century,
early 20th century.
They can't make
clear white flint.
They just didn't have
the capability to do it.
So if you see old
bottles, you'll
see they're all like this.
So I have to go to Italy to
find someone that made it.
But then have a stand out
label that has modern cues
that people would expect.
And our symbolism is a
Phoenix rising from a pot
still to symbolize the revival
of distilling in the city,
but also revival of our family's
involvement in the category.
And our tag line is
The Spirit of Dublin.
And the reason why we
say The Spirit of Dublin,
it's not about
making alcohol in it,
it's trying to capture
that unique DNA that makes
Dublin the city that it is.
It's a bit gritty.
It's got its own sense of humor.
It's got its good, it's
got its bad points,
but it's very resilient.
And there's a reason
why you guys are here.
There's a reason why Google have
the European, Middle Eastern
headquarters here.
It's because of the people
and the environments
that it creates.
And I wanted to capture
that and try and put that
into a bottle of
whiskey, so that's
what The Spirit of
Dublin means to us.
And, as you said, we're urban
distillers through the ages.
So that is not what our
family distillery looked like.
What actually happened
was our family distillery
went through a couple of
different generations.
It got subsumed into a
much larger distillery that
was set up by William Jameson,
who was John Jameson's son,
and became the Marrowbone
Lane Distillery.
So it's the site,
but a lot smaller.
And this is our new
distillery today.
First new distillery in
Dublin for over 125 years.
It took me nearly three years to
get it built, just for planning
reasons and so forth.
Even though it has all that
history and all the kind
of old distilleries
based around it,
and one of the biggest breweries
in the world, Guinness,
it still was exceedingly
difficult to get
Dublin City Council
to back me to be
able to build a distillery.
Because they wanted
to move industry,
like manufacturing,
dirty manufacturing,
as they see it, out of the city.
So it was a fight in our
hands, but lucky enough,
it was worth the effort to get
it because it's our brand home.
And as you can
see, we like to say
we fit into the
palette of materials
that are famous
around The Liberties,
but it's a modern distillery.
We didn't want to
create a pastiche.
You can't recreate history.
Let's create a new history.
And that's more
interesting to me,
and I think that's more
interesting for people.
And if you come and see
us, that's where we are.
Again, New Market
Square, where we are,
is part of the old
part of the city.
It has so much heritage and
stories I won't go into today.
But our previous family
distillery was up around there.
So not too far away.
But we're urban
craft distillers.
And when you come to
see our distillery,
the hero is manufacturing.
You actually see a real
manufacturing location.
It's not a visitor
center with a distillery.
It's a distillery
with a visitor center.
So it's a medium
sized distillery
with real people making
real whiskey seven days
a week, bringing back
the smells, the sounds,
and the environmental
experience.
And once you see it, it's
a very simple process.
It's been made the same
way for hundreds of years,
if not thousands of years.
It's literally make a
beer, and then you distill.
You actually extract
impurities, extract water,
and you're left with your
spirits, which then you
have to mature for
three years and a day.
And what we focus on
is being different.
So we're small.
We're tiny.
We're like-- I
wouldn't say a pimple
on the arse of an elephant,
but we're quite small.
Maybe our competitors
see us like that.
But what we want to do is
we don't want to take away.
We're not trying to rob
volume from the market.
We're trying to create
choice for people.
When they want to
discover something
interesting within the
category, they can come to us,
and hopefully we're different.
Our liquid is different.
We take a lot of pride in
the liquid that goes into it.
Because the one thing I
learned at an early age
was you got to
create a world class
whiskey to get in the game.
To win the game, you have to
create a world class brand.
And we're working on that.
We're not there yet.
But we wanted to create very,
very different tasting whiskeys
so that you can have any
other brand's out there,
and ours will stand out,
and hopefully stand out
for the right reasons.
And you have to have everything
else that goes with it.
So we have a premium
price versus-- let's
say we're around 25%, 30%
higher than the market leader.
We've differentiated packaging,
and hopefully our story
is different as well.
And bring it all together,
hopefully we can create
something that's--
as we say, a little off center.
So this is our small batch.
This is our flagship product.
And the reason why
we went with this
because 90% of Irish whiskey
sales are blended whiskey.
It's a blend of grain
and malt whiskey.
Grain whiskey is made
from corn or maize.
It's very light.
And blending it with
heavier style pot
stilled or single malt makes
it more accessible, easier
to drink, and it's
cheaper as well.
So 90% of all Irish
whiskey sold is that type,
and that's what people
expect and that's
what they get used to.
But we came out a
little bit different.
We said, well, look, let's
treat that blended whiskey
with respect and put it
in interesting barrels
and treat it like it
was a single malt,
and our small batch was born.
So we take a grain
and malt whiskey
that's been aged for around
six years in bourbon barrels,
we blend it
together, and then we
let it marry in rum barrels
for an extra year or so,
and it imparts this
extra layer of flavor.
And we bottle it at 46% or
92 proof, which captures
all the natural flavors.
So it dials up that
taste experience.
But it tastes like what people
expect and they enjoy already.
So creating a ladder of
different things to get people
discovering something new.
And we create a whole range
of different expressions
for people.
So ranging from our Spirit of
Dublin poitin, which is new
make spirits straight
off the still.
So it's traditionally
very strong
where you only bottle
it at 55%, but it still
puts hair on your chest.
Doesn't put it on your
head, unfortunately.
I've tried many times.
To our Teeling Trinity Range,
which is our small batch,
and then we break the
individual components
into a bottling of single grain
whiskey and single malt. Again,
using very innovative casks
to impart unique flavor.
And then we're
lucky-- we have some
of the oldest Irish
single malt available,
and we've created a range
of different expressions
all the way up to a
33-year-old, which
to me is a piece of
Irish whiskey history
that we're just very lucky to
be able to celebrate, and ties
into celebrating the past,
while at the same time doing
something different.
What have we achieved?
You know, it's six
years now, so better
have done something by now.
So we're the fastest growing
Irish whiskey domestically,
which I take a lot of pride in.
So to be a real
brand, you've got
to be relevant to
people in your backyard
and put a lot of
time and effort in.
Irish whiskey 10 years
ago, no one gave a damn.
It was very much focused
on bigger brands.
They didn't really want
to discover anything else.
But it's totally evolved,
it's totally changed.
Now every bar, every
restaurant takes
pride in their back bar, and
particularly Irish whiskey,
Irish gin, and everything
else that's going on.
So it's changed a lot,
but we're delighted to be
part of that evolution.
We're exporting to over
60 international markets.
But it's like the 80-20 rule.
The US, global travel retail,
some bigger markets like that.
That drives most of our volume
and will continue to do so.
We're seeding in Asia and
some emerging markets,
but we're probably
a little bit more
for when people already
know Irish whiskey
and want to discover
something new.
That's where we come in.
We've won over 175 international
awards, which definitely you
take a lot of pride in.
And we'll continue to focus
on one bottle at a time.
And we like to say-- we put
our bottling date on it.
And I get to put my signature
on it because I actually
have the right, the joy,
the obligation to sign off
every batch before we do it.
So it sounds great, but
you had a busy weekend
and you come in on a Monday
morning and they're like,
oh, we have to bottle.
Taste this.
And you're drinking
castor and whiskey.
Sounds a lot more romantic
than it actually is.
But it's still not a bad
job, so I can't complain.
But I do.
I complain all the time.
We've had over 300,000 visitors
through, which is amazing,
which is great, because
we don't have money
for global advertising budgets.
What we want is that
experiential marketing.
So people to come
and experience us;
meet the young, passionate
people we have working for us;
understand what we're
all about; and then
take that home with
them, no matter
where you are in the world.
So it's a key thing.
And that was part
of the reason we
had to fight to
get our distillery,
because we wanted that
experience side of the business
as well.
And you'll be
delighted to know--
I'm talking a lot
about the small batch
and I'm talking a lot
about the distillery.
We have some free
passes and some whiskeys
there for you guys to take
with you so you can really
experience what we're
all about as well.
And where are we now in 2018?
Since I started the company,
the category has doubled.
Well, nearly doubled.
Segmentation is accelerating.
And what we had before,
we were limited by supply.
Going forward from
where we are now,
it's going to be
limited by demand.
So it puts a lot
more onus on us to
perfect our digital
marketing and other tools
that we can leverage
to connect and tell
our story in a meaningful way
to our target demographic.
Our goal for the next
three to four years
is to really be that global
discovery Irish whiskey driving
the premiumization
of Irish whiskey.
Not trying to be the next
Jameson, or [INAUDIBLE],,
or anything like that.
It's to really help
the category evolve
and to give that choice so
that when you go-- no matter
where you go in the
world, rather than one
bottle of Irish whiskey, you'll
see a range of Irish whiskey.
And that's the
opportunity, but that's
the charge at the same time.
And it's getting
more challenging
because this is
what's happening,
and there's definitely
a revolution going on.
There's no shortage of
entrepreneurship in Ireland.
That's the one thing
I can definitely say,
is that everyone
sees the opportunity.
I'm not sure if they're all
going to be able to grasp it
or not.
So the ones in the red were
the original distilleries
from when I set up that were
there, the ones in the green
are the ones that are there
now, and the ones in the black
are some of the ones,
there's even more,
that are going to come up.
So it's very exciting.
It's very noisy.
Hopefully if everyone
focuses on doing something
a little bit different, a
little bit more interesting,
and embrace their own
story and location,
the future looks
very, very bright.
So [INAUDIBLE].
[APPLAUSE]
Am I on track?
Actually, I'm ahead of track.
[INAUDIBLE] loads of questions.
SPEAKER 1: So Jack, thank
you so much for coming.
This has been a very
interesting talk
that I've witnessed as part
of the Talks at Google team.
I'm not talking about whiskey.
But my first question, my
very serious first question
is, have you ever been
drunk on Teeling whiskey,
and would you
recommend experience?
JACK TEELING: Oh, my god.
Well, I can tell you my
first experience with whiskey
was not the best.
SPEAKER 1: Was it because
it wasn't Teeling whiskey?
JACK TEELING: I
didn't know how to--
the problem with people who
don't maybe know whiskey
and how to drink it is that
if you try and drink it
like wine or beer,
you'll drink it too fast.
You have to drink it
in a different way.
So you sip it,
you appreciate it.
So if you drink
it too fast, it'll
hit you like a steam train.
Unfortunately, when
I was growing up,
no one told me that.
Yeah.
It can really knock
your socks off.
We're all about drinking
less and drinking better.
So it's about more
flavor, more character,
and enjoying and
appreciating the whiskey,
rather than drinking
it just to get drunk.
But the medicinal benefits
of it are very relaxing.
It's good to have--
especially after a
hard week in work.
It's a good way to unwind.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
So it's about drinking
less, but drinking better.
JACK TEELING: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: That's very
philosophical for whiskey, no?
JACK TEELING: Well, it's not.
It's happened a lot in
different categories.
Let's say tequila.
Tequila used to be
always just a shot.
Part of the experience of--
I wouldn't say college
experience for people.
Now if you're trying
tequila, it's all about
understanding the
care and effort that
goes into creating the product.
And if you understand
that, you'll appreciate it
a little bit more and you'll
drink it in a different way
as well.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
So you definitely recommend--
I just want to know.
So do you recommend--
JACK TEELING: I
definitely recommend
drinking continuing tea
and whiskey, but not
too much that you make
poor life decisions.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
I'm really curious.
I have a question
for you as a CEO.
If you could describe for us
your worst or your best day
in business, what would that be?
JACK TEELING: Oh, geeze.
Tough question.
Well, I'm lucky that we've
had some key landmark
days along the journey.
This year, 2018, is a
key landmark year for us
as a whiskey distillery because
it's three years and a day
before you can legally sell it.
So we're actually bottling
up our very first release
of our Teeling Single Pot still,
which will be coming available
later in the year.
So it's amazing to have
just a concept that you've
had floating around in your head
to actually build it, lay it
down, and let it mature
over that period of time,
and then see it come to life.
So this year is a
big year for us.
But also it's like the
original five year business
plan has, let's say,
happened, and now we
have to reinvigorate
ourselves and go again.
So all the things we want to
do-- let's get distilling back,
have a range of our
whiskeys, win awards,
do all that kind of
stuff like that--
we've done that.
So how would you
refire the organization
to aspire to something bigger
again, and even myself?
That was a key challenge.
In terms of bad days, I always
find the worst thing is around
people and sometimes
the challenges
that human resources can have.
Some bad decisions
I've had at hiring
to be negative for the company,
and so forth, and creating
not the type of environment
for staff that you want.
And there were some of
the worst times for us,
but that's just normal
in an organization.
But still, I'm lucky.
I struggle sometimes to say,
what was your worst decision
or what's the worst day?
Thankfully, I don't
think I've had it yet.
But it's been a real positive
and enjoyable experience for me
so far.
SPEAKER 1: My next
question is around legacy.
So you're running
the company that
has had a lot of history,
a lot of family history,
but at the same time
you're running it
in the 21st century where things
are changing very rapidly.
So how have you been able
to marry the traditional
with the contemporary?
So retaining your core identity,
but then also adapting it
for the youngins like us?
JACK TEELING: I'm not that old.
SPEAKER 1: No, not you.
Not you.
JACK TEELING: I'm
getting older, but--
I used to say our target
demographic was 21 to 35.
Now it has to be 21 to 45.
But I suppose in
any kind of business
where your name is
on the bottle or it's
gone through lots of
different generations,
there's a lot of pressure
and ownership on you
to represent in the right way.
Not screw it up.
Ours is a little bit
different in that
it's really a kind of revival of
the trademark and the history.
So we're a little
bit more, let's say,
not as hampered by some
of the legacy issues.
But what we're trying to do is
when people think of Teeling
or they hear the name, they
go, oh, like the whiskey.
You know, so that's
where we want to go.
And I think our wider family,
which is quite a small--
Teeling is an
unusual Irish name.
Actually came from
Vikings, Normans, when they
came to Ireland many years ago.
There's more Teelings in Holland
than anywhere else, which
I only found out once I set
up the company when they all
kept phoning up asking for
free bottles of whiskey.
I think it's an
amazing opportunity
that I've been given to put our
mark back on Dublin whiskey.
And hopefully it can go through
a couple different generations
and carry on that
legacy to [INAUDIBLE]..
SPEAKER 1: My final question--
so if you have a question,
just get ready.
My final question is,
when you were speaking,
you said that to date you've
had about 300,000 visitors
at the distillery.
That's a lot of people.
And you also said something
around digital marketing,
on trying to adapt
for the digital age.
So really quick question.
Do you have an AdWords account?
JACK TEELING: Yes.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
JACK TEELING: Very much so.
Yeah.
It's a key--
SPEAKER 1: I'm just joking.
[LAUGHTER]
JACK TEELING: [INAUDIBLE].
It is.
Because the hardest thing is
in our industry, just so many--
we don't have our
own distributors.
So we have distributors,
independent distributors
around the world.
And it's sometimes
like Chinese whispers,
but you're telling your story.
And you say to them-- and
they kind of go, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I understand.
They've no idea what
you're talking about.
And then they tell
their sales guys,
who then tells the barman,
who tells then the consumer,
and they kind of
lose that impact.
So modern digital communication
cuts through all the noise.
So someone on their
phone could find you
and hopefully understand what
your product is all about
and what your
brand is all about.
SPEAKER 1: Thanks for
pitching AdWords back to me.
I'm going to use that in
my next client meetings.
Are there questions from the--
oh, perfect.
JACK TEELING: And the
best question, I've
got a big bottle.
So no pressure.
SPEAKER 1: I think
I should get it.
JACK TEELING: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Since we
are here at Google,
I want to know, like, which
is your favorite YouTube
channel talking about whiskey?
And one less thing, what do you
think about Conor McGregor's
new Proper Twelve?
JACK TEELING: Probably the
first one is a guy called Ralfy.
I don't know if you know Ralfy.
He's a serious character.
And he's been doing
it for a long time.
He must be out there way
before the modern interest
in online reviews.
And he's very
independent as well.
He's Scottish, which
is a bit of an issue.
So he has this warped
view of Irish whiskey,
but I enjoy the way he does
and his tasting [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Do you
remember your score?
JACK TEELING:
We've got a couple.
I think we did reasonably
OK on the small batch.
I think he likes the
older expressions.
Our single malt in particular
he gave us a good score.
And then Conor McGregor
is an interesting one
because he sent in his
negotiator to us a couple of--
I'd say maybe two years ago.
A guy called Artem Lobov,
who is The Russian Hammer.
He's an MMA fighter as well.
But he is a friend of
Conor, and he was looking
at getting supply of whiskey.
AUDIENCE: Real negotiator.
JACK TEELING: Real negotiator.
It was funny because he had
no knuckles on his hand.
I was like, oh.
He's really small.
Like, you know,
maybe I can take him.
And I said, not a chance.
And he'd just finished
a business degree,
so he was going around
doing-- so Conor has
had an interest for a while.
We pitched an idea of doing
a very limited, high end
kind of one for him,
but he wanted something
that was a little bit more
entry level to kind of go
after a wider
opportunity, and it
was something we couldn't do.
And his launch has
been phenomenal.
It's definitely generated
a lot of interest.
I would be interested to see
how that interest maintains
over the weekends.
But I was in a taxi and he's an
MMA fighter, the taxi driver,
and he said, guaranteed going
to knock out in the first round.
So he's putting his
own money on it.
So it could be an extra
kick for his whiskey.
But I think more people
talking about Irish whiskey,
it's good because it's still at
the early stages of evolution.
But we do something that's
quite different than Conor.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks first for
your presentation.
Really engaging.
A question around this
distillery and what
you're producing in there.
So I've been to this
distillery in New Market.
It's a very impressive set
up of the merchandise store.
Not like the paddywhack
O'Carroll's you mentioned.
But showed us an Irish family of
whiskeys, and one of them I saw
was poitin.
So I actually went to
the launch of this.
It was paired with
Poachers, an Irish gin,
which I thought was
really great that you're
supporting Irish business.
Where do you see this in
terms of your target market,
and how can this become a
drink like a cocktail or--
JACK TEELING: With poitin,
or just whiskey in general?
AUDIENCE: With poitin, actually.
JACK TEELING: Yeah.
Well, poitin is-- I've been
interested in poitin for a long
time because it is--
everyone in Ireland
has some story about--
mostly not good-- about poitin.
It always comes out at special
occasions, wakes, or stags,
or all this kind
of stuff like that.
Or someone has a
bottle somewhere
underneath the counter in
the 7-Up or whatever sort
of bottle.
And I always thought it
was a great opportunity
to represent in a
more modern way,
but it's hard because people
don't know how to drink,
and it's a bit of a novelty
because it's so strong.
And you're competing
against other white spirits,
be it vodka or anything else.
So it's a difficult one.
And we've tried it and
it's part of the portfolio,
but it's-- so much money would
go into changing consumer
behaviors and education that
for us, it's nice to have,
put our real opportunity
is in whiskey,
which people already understand
and it's a global opportunity.
And there's one or
two guys like Micil
which is out in Galway,
which that's what he does.
He's a poitin maker
and I think he's trying
to do some good things as well.
But I think it would
be in cocktails
and understanding
maybe a signature drink
that poitin can live
in to really give it--
but it's up against gin,
which, again, it's gone crazy.
But I'd like to see a
future because we have a GI.
So it's a geographically
protected terminology
that's solely from Ireland.
So it's there to
be exploited, but I
would like to see a
bigger company probably do
a lot of the heavy lifting to
get it to where it needs to be.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
My question is about,
how do you start
or how do you
revive a distillery,
presuming that you need
to have a whiskey that's
been aged for 12 years
or 15, maybe even 25?
And I know you're selling
some 25-year-old whiskeys.
And then in the same way, how
do you deal with competition?
How do you anticipate that
people who are kids today
are going to love your
whiskey in 10 or 15 years
and that some other
distillery is not
going to come out with
something revolutionary
that you couldn't
deal with later?
For example, I was thinking
how Japan entered the whiskey
market in 2010 or
2014 out of the blue,
and now they're kind of leading
it, getting the rewards.
How do you deal with that?
JACK TEELING: Yeah.
I said no tough questions.
We got, how do you have
whiskeys and you're
only a new distillery?
That's a very good question.
And I was the managing director
in Cooley when it was sold.
I wasn't happy when
it was being sold,
so I was a little
bit problematic
and I demanded the
supply contract
to be able to stay within
the industry, which
they gave, which was great,
so there's no non-compete.
Allowed me to get back
into the category.
And in 2012 and
'13, an opportunity
came to buy a big chunk of
inventory, which we acted on.
And so we knew quite well.
But what we focus on is changing
and making it different.
And by using innovative
cask maturation
to bring that extra
flavor onto it
And I suppose where
we're coming now
is full circle where we're
replacing that source whiskey
with our own whiskey now.
Now it allows us to be truly
innovative and doing things
differently.
In terms of when we set
up, were we producing
whiskeys that people would like?
I suppose we were our
target demographic.
It was literally the
group that was involved
with opening the distillery.
We sat around and said, look
what do we find interesting?
What do we like?
If we like it, we hope
other people like it.
So we're the toughest
critics, but we
make whiskeys we like to drink,
and hopefully other people
like to drink it as well.
And going forward, how
can we keep it relevant?
How can we keep it exciting?
But innovating, if you ask me.
And so we're laying down
whiskeys-- peated whiskeys,
smoky whiskeys, rye whiskeys--
lots of different styles
so that hopefully we
can respond to consumer
interest for different things.
But it's global.
People make whiskey everywhere.
Japanese whiskey's amazing.
Taiwanese whiskeys are amazing.
Australian whiskey
is everywhere.
So I think people are more
interested what's in the bottle
rather than it necessarily has
to be from a certain country.
So that puts more
pressure, but also opens up
a lot of opportunities
because Irish whiskey is still
quite small.
It used to be only scotch.
Scotch, scotch, scotch.
Now it's everyone is open
to trying different things.
AUDIENCE: So a lot
of whiskey ends up
getting around 45% proof.
There have been some really
interesting products that
are typically higher in proof.
So 50%, 60% cask strength.
Can you talk a
little bit about how
that might be a potential
direction for you,
or just in the
industry in general?
JACK TEELING: Yeah.
I think a lot of
American whiskeys
will be quite high in
alcohol, and that's, again,
because of the maturation.
So because they mature in very
hot climates, they actually--
rather than in Ireland
where you lose alcohol
into the atmosphere, you lose--
SPEAKER 1: So breathing alcohol.
JACK TEELING: Yeah.
It's called the angel's share.
It's our profit
going up in the air.
So the smell you get
at a whiskey warehouse
is actually alcohol
disappearing into ether.
Put it's that environmental
influence that
makes whiskey what it is.
So in hotter climates, it
goes up rather than goes down.
So the longer you have
it in wood in Ireland,
the lower the alcohol strength.
In America and
Taiwan, it goes up.
But I think also, people
want to have a fuller
flavor, a stronger
flavor, and I think
people's palates can evolve.
And we do a lot of
single cask bottlings.
You can come to our distillery,
fill a single cask directly
from the cask, and
it could be anywhere
from 62% all the way down
to-- we bottled a 34-year-old
and it was at 43.1%.
That was the actual cask
strength coming out of it.
So it just depends.
And what we like to do is cater
for a full range of tastes.
And when you have
the casks strength,
you can add water
to it to get it to--
but all our whiskeys,
our signature is 46%.
And the reason why we do
that is because if you
bottle at 40%, which
is the legal limit--
that's the lowest.
It's obviously cheaper to also.
But you also have
to do a process--
it's called chill filtration.
Because if you don't do that,
if you get it from hot to cold,
you get this clouding and little
bits of esters and fatty acids
coagulating.
And so you go, geeze, what's
floating in my whiskey?
But if you bottle it at a
higher alcohol strength,
you can keep them in.
So we're trying to
bring more flavor in.
And our view is, why would
you take those naturally
occurring flavors out?
Because they give it a
lovely, velvety mouthfeel.
So we're all over that.
And one of our
Brabazon bottling,
which is a single malt
bottling, again, we
picked 49.5% alcohol because it
delivered the best [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you.
My question is actually
related to trends
in new product development.
So you've touched
upon the competition
and the big brand trying to
steal within the category.
But it's also happening is cross
category, major manufacturers
and small brands competing and
coming up with great ideas.
Like in the UK, they've
invented the collagen
based gin, which is--
JACK TEELING: I saw that.
That was--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: It was.
Indeed.
Yes.
So I'm wondering, what
is happening in whiskey?
Because it's quite
traditional in terms of taste.
Are there any crazy
or interesting ideas
coming around?
JACK TEELING: Well, because
it's such an old industry,
there's lots of
rules and regulations
that you have to operate within.
What's interesting in Ireland
is the rules and regulations
say it has to be matured
in wooden barrels for three
years and a day to be
legally called Irish whiskey.
But if you go to Scotland,
it's oak barrels.
So what you're
seeing now is people
are using different
types of wood
to try and impart extra flavor.
So chestnut, acacia, cherrywood.
We even have experimented
with Brazilian hardwood.
Sustainably
forested, I must add.
And it's weird.
It's just a weird
thing because it
tastes like you have
a grand piano when
you put your nose into it.
It tastes like that.
Don't ask me how, but it does.
It's really weird.
But you can do that.
What we are doing a
lot of is collaborating
with other spirits producers.
Be it craft breweries,
other spirits producers.
So we've casks that would have
been used for aquavit, for gin,
for vermouth, for craft beer,
for anything you can imagine.
You can do it because that
imparts a certain flavor
into the barrel that you can
then extract into the whiskey.
You can't add any flavorings,
like natural flavorings
or anything like
that, otherwise it
can't be classified as whiskey.
But you can basically
use a wooden vessel
that has been used to age
or mature something else.
And we do a lot with different
types of wines and stuff
like that.
So we're innovating
where we can.
And also you can
innovate how you
want raw materials used and
even the yeast strains you use.
So we're using a
combination of white wine
yeast and traditional
[INAUDIBLE]
to produce a very
flavorsome base
that you make your spirit from.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So you mentioned how
your challenges so far
have been supply
based challenges,
but they're now moving more
towards the demand side.
So I'm guessing that
you are thinking
about how to increase
demand, and one way to do
that is by scaling globally.
So I'm just curious.
How do you maintain a local
brand and make that go global?
Like, how do you stay
quintessentially Irish and true
to your heritage?
Because this is a business
that has been inherited, right?
So how do you stay true to that
while having a global appeal?
JACK TEELING: Yeah.
That's a very good question.
Like you guys know THE
local type of approach,
in terms of what we
do here in Dublin.
The different things
we do to try and engage
with local communities.
We try and foster a similar type
of behavior from our importers
around the world to
bring the brand to life.
So at the core, we
are definitely Irish
and we're Dublin.
And sometimes you
go around the world,
they don't understand Dublin.
You go to New York
and they still
think there's, like, donkeys
going through the streets
and stuff like that.
No, no, no.
It's a challenge.
It is a challenge.
And it's easy if you
live here to understand
what the city is like.
To try and capture
that in an emotive way
and to bring us internationally,
it's a challenge.
And I wouldn't say we've cracked
it, but we're working on it.
What we do is we have
Irish people that we've
sent around the world
to represent the brand
to bring it to life.
Brand ambassadors.
Whiskey warriors, as
we like to call them,
because they're at
the coalface fighting
to go battle to spread the
gospel of all things Teeling.
And that's going into probably
the right type of accounts
where people take pride
in what they sell.
They want to learn.
And then they can tell
your story for you.
So it's an ongoing battle.
AUDIENCE: Increasingly,
purchasing whiskey
is being driven by
investment decision
rather than for consumption.
And a couple of days
ago, there was an article
going viral about
the Macallan selling
for nearly a million euro.
I was wondering,
for people like us
who can hold whiskey for
another 30, 40 years at least,
what sort of
recommendation would you
have in terms of
what type of whiskey
we should be purchasing?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JACK TEELING: Have
you all signed
disclosures in this on one?
I don't know [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: And perhaps
just to relate back
to your company, is there
any specific type of Teeling
whiskey that maybe we should--
or you would envisage surging
in price going forward?
JACK TEELING: I always
encourage people to at least buy
two bottles so they can drink
one and collect the other one.
But at the core of our range,
we make whiskeys to be drunk.
Whiskey is, for me--
it's enjoyed with social.
Buy it, open, and drink it.
And we've positioned
our core range
so that it wouldn't gather dust
in people's drinks cabinets.
It's an affordable luxury.
So at the core, that's
what we're all about.
But as a category, Irish
whiskey is booming.
It's growing ahead of
everyone's expectations.
So the ability to
sell older expressions
is going to become more limited.
And as more and more
collectors come in,
there's going to be
a high appreciation.
And what we're seeing
is a lot of interest
in the newer
distilleries like Dingle
and older things like that.
People are just buying to sell
on, and it seems to be working.
But is it a house of cards that
they're selling to each other
and it's going to implode?
I don't know.
But I think anything
that has-- it's
like a bit of liquid history.
And some of the older
expressions, I would expect--
I can't guarantee-- that they
should appreciate in value
as more and more collectors
come into the category
as it gets bigger.
So still at the early stages.
I remember 5, 10
years ago, no one
really collected Irish whiskey.
Now you go online and there's
massive communities that
are all talking about
it, but still small
relative to Scotch or Japanese.
And we auctioned off
our very first release
from the distillery on
whiskeyauctioneer.com,
a Scottish one.
And we did it because we
wanted to achieve the highest
price so we could give
all the proceeds back
to local charities.
So give something back.
And our bottle number one, which
is a three-year-old whiskey,
sold for 10,000 pounds sterling,
which I thought was great.
But on average, they went
for 600 pounds as well.
But that's a once off,
never to be repeated.
Our commercial release
of our single pot
still will be coming out
in October, November.
Batch one will be priced
hopefully reasonably enough.
Around 50, 55 euros.
So again, drinkable.
But if you were to
put away a bottle,
I would recommend that one.
SPEAKER 1: Thank
you so much, Jack.
I never knew, like,
coming to a whiskey talk,
I would take away
a nugget for life.
Drink less, drink better.
Yeah.
So do less, do better.
Just anything
less, do it better.
JACK TEELING: I cannot choose
who asked the best question.
Going to have leave that to you.
SPEAKER 1: Yay!
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much, guys.
Thank you.
Thank you, Jack.